during the 15 years that sam and dean
winchester went around saving people and
hunting things in a 67 chevy impala and
supernatural the series reduced its
fandom to a messy puddle of tears
however the show's second and final swan
song cuts the deepest
supernatural creator eric kripke's no
angel policy came to a fiery halt with
castiel way back in season four
this particular trench coat wearing
angel spends just over a decade
unlearning thousands of years of angel
bias and brutality
even from his first few lines castiel
understands dean like no one else has
not even sam what's the matter
you don't think you deserve to be saved
despite dean's bravado and snark castiel
understands how dean perceives himself
as a destructive angry broken man
daddy's blunt instrument
in the third the last episode despair
cass finally tells dean the truth when
he sacrifices himself to the empty
a plane of non-existence where angels go
when they die
having made a deal in season 14 that
would send him to the empty the moment
he experiences happiness
castiel fulfills that pact while finally
confessing his love for dean winchester
happiness isn't in
the having it's in just being
dean asks why the monologue sounds like
a goodbye and cass confirms fans long
time suspicions when he says three words
i love you and those three words save
the world
cass leaves dean with a bloody handprint
a mirror of the handprint scar left on
dean's shoulder when castiel gripped him
and raised him from perdition in season
four
the gesture is one final corporeal mark
of the profound bond
in a relationship that is as long
important and formative to who a person
or angel is there's a moment when
someone has to decide if they're going
to allow the experience to break them or
affect them positively
when cass looks back at his time with
dean he realizes that the hunter's true
feelings about him don't matter
castiel's confession isn't about dean
it's about him finally getting in touch
with his deepest human emotions
cass accepts himself with no apology or
fear of rejection
setting himself free what was once a
relationship built on subtext has turned
into text making it clear that cass is
in love with dean winchester
because the one thing i want
something i know i can't have whether
dean feels the same
is up for debate but the angel's
feelings on the matter are pretty
explicit
there are plenty of platonic and
familial love confessions in the show
this isn't one of them so what happens
when you try to bargain with a ruthless
god named chuck
after he wipes out humanity thanos style
inherit the earth essentially serves as
the season 15 finale leaving one final
episode to wrap up the series
despite dean and sam bargaining to
fulfill chuck's perverted cain and abel
fratricide fantasy to save humanity god
has once again become bored with his
story
dean is ready to give up when jack feels
the archangel michael
years after abandoning their surprise
half-brother adam and hell
sam asked michael what happened to his
once vessel and adam
i'm gone to say exterminated by my
father
neither winchester seems to care all
that much when dean obligatorily
responds with
poor bastard never caught a break and
it's kind of hard to catch a break when
your brothers let you rot in hell for a
decade though
lucifer has decimated the world toyed
with humanity and jump-started the
apocalypse
but impersonating a very dead castiel to
get into the bunker is his most
blasphemous crime
wow way to treat a pal satan may have
thrown the biggest temper tantrum in the
history of the universe when he rebelled
but all he ever wanted was daddy's love
and that goes for michael too unlike
dean and sam however michael and lucifer
fall in line with chuck's perverse plan
which allows the winchesters to draw a
chuck out ever the forgiving lord
depicted in the bible chuck smites his
favorite son for having ever sided with
the winchesters even briefly
however chuck's deepest flaw is
underestimating human resilience
especially when it comes to the
winchesters dean and sam refuse to give
up as chuck mercilessly breaks their
bones
staying in the fight long enough for
jack to show up to save the day
when jack absorbs chuck's powers
rendering him mortal chuck accepts his
impending
kind of glorious but the winchesters
don't give him what he wants
instead they leave him pitiful wailing
on the ground to age and die like a
regular mortal
cass tells dean that the hunter changed
him during his death scene but the angel
changed dean
too after a lifetime of self-hatred
castiel's admission finally convinces
dean that he's more than the ultimate
killer
see that's not who i am while dean isn't
able to tell cass he loves him back
whether he feels it romantically or not
he honors cass's memory by finally
loving himself castiel believes that
everything dean does is for love and
dean is hell-bent on proving him right
the hunter finally acknowledges his
self-worth and leaves chuck to his
powered down pathetic existence
both brothers choose justice over
revenge finally moving past the motive
that's driven their actions for 15 years
talk about character growth castiel
actor misha collins told the creation
entertainment panel that it was the
ending he'd always imagined for cass
saying it felt like it was a little
risky and a little brave for the show to
do
and i was happy to be part of that and
to be able to have castiel express love
like that
those who seek power will never use it
well it was true for chuck and it would
have been true for billy
death if cass hadn't orchestrated her
death to his sacrifice but jack has only
ever wanted to do good and make his
surrogate dads proud
and despite castiel's earlier assurances
that jack doesn't need to live for
anyone else he accomplishes both
as it turns out when you become god it's
time to leave the nest spread those
angel wings and learn to fly
after jack fixes the destruction chuck
brought to the world he says goodbye to
the boys
i'll be in every drop of falling rain
every speck of dust but the wind blows
the most crucial aspect of jack's
farewell is his restoration of free will
he promises not to insert himself in the
story and dean appears to stop himself
from asking about bringing cass back
before jack declares that he's always as
close as their hearts
castiel and jack may not be winchesters
by name but they earned a place at the
table
dean and sam having carved the
pseudo-winchester's names alongside
their own
thanks to jack and cass they're finally
free to write their own stories honoring
everyone they lost along the way
and i'm good with who i am
i'm good with who you are because our
lives
they're ours kripke notes that the han
solo and luke skywalker vibe of dean and
sam and this backroads americana story
is what makes the show
work the series starts with two brothers
and it has to end on that relationship
the winchesters spend 15 years fighting
for freedom so what do they do when they
get it
sam pies dean and long time supernatural
producer robert singer laughs in the
background of the scene carry on the
final episode opens on the appropriately
named song
ordinary life dean and sam aren't the
protagonists in some screwed up cosmic
story anymore
on their final hunt they pose as agents
eric kripke and bob singer taking down a
nest of vampires and saving two young
brothers
here they set up a new generation of
hunters because dean could never live an
apple pie life
and sam wouldn't stop hunting until he
did but dean and sam winchester are
regular hunters now
and regular hunters die regular gruesome
deaths when a vamp shoves dean into a
rebar he fulfills the destiny of going
down swinging
not usually a man of many words dean
ends up telling sam all the things he's
held back since they were kids
mirroring jack's goodbye he tells sam
that he can always find him in his heart
he then makes reference to actor jared
padilecki's mental health charity
campaign
telling his brother to quote always keep
fighting it's okay
[Music]
you can go now sam doesn't make a demon
deal or ask jack to bring his brother
back
instead he gives dean a hunter's funeral
to the song brothers in arms by dire
straits
subtly referencing dean's bon jovi rocks
on occasion line from season 3 a morning
sam feinstein's cell ringing
hello um hi agent bon jovi
uh this is agent bon jovi
after the hunt sam honors dean by living
the normal life he never could
and by naming his only son after his
fallen brother after generations of
family heartache sam winchester breaks
the winchester cycle of absent fathers
and demon deals
padelecki explained in a creation
entertainment panel sam tried to live
his life the way dean would have wanted
him to live his life if dean were to
come back to life 20 years later and sam
was still hunting i think dean would
have been pissed off
while we can't be sure if little dean
has taken up hunting and elderly sam
seems surprised to see the matching
pentagram tattoo sporting
dean says the same words to his father
that sam said to his brother all those
years ago
it's okay you can go now
then still wearing his brother's old
watch sam dies peacefully
a heaven where souls live out their
golden oldies on repeat for the rest of
eternity would never be good enough for
the winchesters who sacrificed
everything to save the world
so while jack promised not to intervene
in human affairs he does fix up heaven
before dean makes it to the pearly gates
dean gets a life with his family in
heaven that he never got on earth
everyone happy and together all within
reach of a pint at harvell's roadhouse
giving dean closure that his parents are
more than a cupid experiment gone wrong
john and mary winchester finally spent
their afterlife together
so jack did all that well
cass helped dean decides to go for a
drive while he waits for sam to join him
kansas's carry-on wayward son plays as
dean takes off in baby's pilot iteration
fit with original license plate
on earth sam can feel the heavenly
connection to dean when he grips the
wheel of the real impala
but time in heaven is different the
song's breath for dean is a lifetime for
sam
after which they meet again on a bridge
hey sammy
[Music]
the final touch the boy's clothing
almost matches their pilot wardrobe as
the lyric now my life's no longer empty
surely heaven waits for you chimes in
the background
supernatural's on-screen send-off wasn't
the original plan
misha collins noted in the original
iteration of the ending cass hadn't gone
to rebuild heaven there was a different
conclusion for him
while the actor didn't give specifics he
elaborated that dean and sam's heaven
was supposed to be populated by their
loved ones from
past but covet 19 prevented it from
happening and quote
a new version had to emerge in a way the
winchester's already got their reunion
scene in the show's 300th episode
lebanon
and the unlikely photo from that family
dinner remains on sam's mantle for the
rest of his days
actress samantha smith explained i just
remember thinking
that scene is perfect this moment of
happiness of having the family all
together
even if it's for one dinner we had never
all four of us been in a scene together
yet it felt like we had been together
the entire show according to patalecki
the script changes wound up being quote
a happy accident the show started out
with sam and dean
that was the show and for it to end like
that full circle was pretty magical
storytelling
still carry on might not be the end of
supernatural in its entirety
dean actor jensen ackles revealed that a
supernatural spin-off would be his dream
project to produce during his warner
brothers deal
additionally sam actor jared padalecki
joked about a reunion in the future so
maybe there's hope yet
regardless no doubt endings are hard
but then again nothing ever really ends
does it supernatural lives on in the
hearts of everyone the show touched
whether it's through the actors charity
organizations or the bonds of found
family
supernatural isn't going anywhere
anytime soon but for fans who really
want to envision their own ending for
the winchesters collins notes
even when the story is written you can
write your own ending check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you